This is one of our clients and they were
able to get over a hundred brand
mentions on chat GPT, 75 times they've
won the AI overviews on Google, they
have 37 citations on Gemini, 129
citations on perplexity, 42 on co-pilot,
and 101
on Grok. And in today's video, I'll be
breaking down exactly how we were able
to get them these citations. So, in
order to rank on AI or get cited by chat
GPT or other AI search engines, you have
to do your research a little bit
different from traditional SEO. We need
to think about fan out terms and terms
that people are searching up and we need
to write our content in a more
structured format for AI. I've already
created a full SOP on AI search ranking.
If you want to get the full SOP, just
comment AI search below. I'll send you
over the full SOP that you can follow
that tells you all about how AI search
engines work and how you can write your
content and the research to rank on AI
search. Before I had to do this all
manually, but now we can use AI to
expedite that process. So, the first
thing that you want to do is you want to
find topics that you can write about.
Now, if we head over to the keyword
research mode in WordRocket and we enter
in any topic here and we click research
keywords, we'll be able to get back some
traditional SEO keywords. Now, this is
great for traditional SEO, but we need
to further do research to get better AI
search questions. Now, in WordRocket, we
can actually go over any of these
keywords here and click AI enrich.
And what's going to happen is we're
going to go out and fetch the most
relevant questions that AI would be
asking about this specific topic. So,
for example, this article is about types
of skin tag. So, good AI or geo
questions would be what are the most
common skin tags? How can I
differentiate between benign skin tags
and potentially dangerous? Are some
people more prone to developing specific
types of skin tags? And so on and so
forth. So, the main difference with AI
searches we need to write content that
is fan out. So, we need to write
questions about the specific search
query that people may be searching. So,
when the AI sites your information and
it's not citing your full article, it's
citing parts of your article. So, you
want to make sure that you're hitting
every single angle of that specific
topic so that AI can cite you. So, if
you wanted to, we can then go simply and
click click generate article. We go to
standard article here and we can see
that the AI search questions have
already been um included in our
additional context. Our topic, our
search term has already been included.
So, it saves us a couple of seconds, but
when you're doing a lot of articles, you
know, it's really adds up.
So, then we can go ahead and enter in
our um sitemap here. Now, what I'm going
to do is I'm also going to toggle on GEO
optimization on Wordtracker. We've
recently made some improvements on on
our GEO optimization so that it's more
of a three-step process. The first
process will go ahead and find even more
questions that people may be asking or
the AI would um want to cite around this
specific topic and and it writes all of
the content in a manner that's GEO
optimized. So, while this article is
ranking, let's go ahead and take a look
at some of the other GEO optimized
articles that we've written about. So,
for example, here is an article about a
specific um a specific peptide. So, we
can see here right away we get the quick
answer. When you're ranking on AI
search, you need to give them the answer
right away. You don't want the AI You
don't want the AI bots that go out and
scrape the internet to have to find or
work to get your articles. So, instead
of having a bloated article with
introduction, with a story, you give the
answer right at the top and that's what
all articles that's GEO optimized on
Wordtracker does. Everything, as you can
see here,
answers the question. So, the question
is what is a alternative for this
specific product? So, the best
alternative for this specific product
can depend on blah blah blah. And then
it gives you an actual answer here,
right? So, within the first couple of
sentences, we get an answer, we get
pricing, we get where we can find it,
and we get closest compar- comparable
options to the um to the actual product
here. And then we get the key takeaways
right away as well. So, all of the most
important relevant information is going
to be in the first couple hundred uh
words of this article. And then with
WordRocket, we create very high-quality
um relevant images throughout your
article. So, for example, if we take a
look at this article here, has different
products, it has their brands, it has
their logos, and everything here is
without any distortion in the text. It's
a beautiful chart, it looks like it's
custom-made, and these are just good
EEAT factors from Google to allow you to
have some authority and to Google to see
that, you know what, you've taken some
time. This is not a a generic article
that you've written about. Then we get
the fan out questions. So, is Mounjaro
the same as Ozempic, right? How much
does it cost? Are there cheaper
alternatives? Is this a good
alternative? Can I get Mounjaro on an
NHS prescription? What are the side
effects? Who shouldn't take it? Which
injection works the best? Which doctors
do you recommend? How do I switch? How
quickly does this product support body
composition changes, right? So on and so
forth. So, you see here
a lot of really really um relevant fan
out questions, right? So, when you're
thinking of ranking on AI, think of your
search term and think of other terms
that fan out that's related to that
term. And again, we had a beautiful
realistic image here. Then we get the
FAQs towards the end. All everything
here is internally linked, and we use
res- references as well. And everything
is well-researched, as we can see.
There's references to actual websites.
So, this again increases your EEAT
because we're writing on information
that is up-to-date and relevant, and
we're including those references. So, if
you actually scroll to the bottom of the
article, we now have a new feature which
allows you to get your GEO insights. So,
out of 13 of the fan out queries, we
actually wrote on 10 of them, which is
pretty good. So, our in terms of our
citation readiness, we are 90 out of
100. So, that means that
this article is GEO optimized, so we can
be confident that we've written on most
of the important fan out questions. So,
we can
be confident that some part of this
article will be cited in AI. So, we need
to think about AI ranking and SEO
differently. SEO, we rank for the pages.
AI, we rank for the paragraphs, right?
So, we want these specific paragraphs to
be cited on ChatGPT, Perplexity, and so
on. Let's go ahead and take a look at
the article that we generated. So,
Understanding Skin Tags, a Comprehensive
Guide. Beautiful, beautiful image here.
As you can see, it it zooms into a skin
tag. Looks very realistic. Then we get
the quick answer. We get the last
updated, which is today's date, May
27th. Then we get the quick answer. So,
skin tags are benign, blah blah blah,
they affect 50 to 60% of adults,
what not and what not. So, again, quick
answer right away. Then we get the key
takeaways again. So, it gives you the
key takeaways about skin tags. And then
we get the fan out questions. What
exactly are skin tags? How do different
skin tags look? And look at these
images, guys. These images are
world-class images here. Right? Um
are skin tags dangerous? Can skin skin
tags turn into cancer? What are the
differences between skin tag and a mole?
Are some people blah blah blah? Do skin
tags ever go away?
Right? Like, this is the type of content
that you need to write in 2026 and
beyond if you want to rank. And Word
Rocket allows you to do it very, very
easily. Then we get our references again
because everything is fact-checked. So,
that again increases our
authoritativeness. And then we get our
fan out questions and our site uh
citation readiness. Citation readiness
is 90 out of 100. Funnel is 10 out of 13
funnel questions we wrote about. So,
again,
you can manually go out and do this, or
you can use WordRocket to discover your
topics, AI enrich to get the actual
keywords or the actual questions, then
pop that over to our generate content
template with the questions, generate
your article, and then you'd be able to
see your AI readiness score and how many
funnel questions you've included with in
that article. You have custom images,
internal links, and you can include your
include your brand voice, and also
everything is research backed. So, I
hope that you guys enjoyed today's
video. If you did, let me know by giving
us a big thumbs up, and I'll see you in
the next one. Take care.